oggi al punto vorrei parlarvi del
dialogo interreligioso e credo che
sappiamo tutti bene l'importanza di
questo discorso proprio in un mondo
molto frammentato molto conflittuale
dove troppe volte in troppi luoghi
spesso si utilizza anche il discorso
religioso per compiere violenze per
combattere contro gli altri
in troppi luoghi si uccide in nome di
dio questo noi lo sappiamo è però questo
discorso del dialogo interreligioso non
è scontato non è scontato perché c'è chi
dice che il dialogo dialogare un modo in
fondo per annacquare la propria identità
religiosa è un cedimento verso gli altri
verso chi magari si vede un po come
estraneo come nemico addirittura è un
indebolimento della propria fede
e poi c'è anche chi così è un po
perplesso su che cosa serva il dialogo
in fondo si parla ci si confronta ci si
incontra e poi però i conflitti
continuano le violenze continuano e
quindi molti dicono che il dialogo in
fondo serve poco non serve a tanto però
io mi chiedo e vi chiedo anche ma cosa
sarebbe il mondo oggi senza il dialogo
cosa sarebbe il mondo dopo l'undici
settembre senza al dialogo tra le
religioni
cosa sarebbero le nostre città penso
milano senza il dialogo tra comunità
religiose che vivono qui e milano è un
laboratorio in italia in europa per il
dialogo è una realtà molto bella molto
importante allora io credo che dobbiamo
appunto riflettere di più su che cosa
significa anche dialogare che cos'è il
dialogo interreligioso in questo senso
la comunità di sant'egidio crede molto a
questo discorso la comunità di
sant'egidio è nata appunto nel 68 a roma
da uno studente 18enne andrea riccardi
era un gruppo di studenti che hanno
iniziato a vivere
un'esperienza un'esperienza cristiana e
oggi appunto sant'egidio è una realtà
internazionale presente in più di 70
paesi in tutti i continenti sono uomini
donne che pregano che vivono il vangelo
che sono amici dei poveri che quindi
vivono un'amicizia concreta e familiare
con chi è più debole e che lavorano per
la pace e lavorare per la pace vuol dire
appunto anche lavorare per il dialogo
interreligioso
allora per spiegare anche che cosa è
meglio il discorso del dialogo
interreligioso
parto da una storia e la storia di
centinaia migliaia di uomini donne
bambini profughi che arrivano sulle
nostre coste
questa immagine è un'immagine molto
eloquente anche particolare una spiaggia
della sicilia l'estate scorsa una
domenica famiglie sulla spiaggia
abbastanza ignare abbastanza una
giornata di vacanza è un certo punto si
materializza un barcone un barcone
carico di ragazzi africani di profughi
di gente che scappa dalle guerre che
scappa soprattutto da situazioni molto
difficili molto dure e come se nella
vita normale di tutti i giorni
irrompesse la storia irrompesse la
domanda è anche un po il grido che viene
da realtà che noi pensiamo lontane ma
che poi sono molto vicine tanto vicine
che ci toccano direttamente che la
incontriamo le tocchiamo e dopo un
inizio di smarrimento queste persone
hanno iniziato poi aiutare questi
profughi e sbarcare son dati da fare per
cercare di aiutare questi ragazzi è la
storia di migliaia di persone l'anno
scorso 170mila persone sono sbarcate
sulle nostre coste hanno attraversato
l'italia perchè sono quasi tutti in
transito più di 50mila sono passati da
milano e gente appunto che sfugge
da situazioni molto difficili penso la
siria
penso di rak penso a tante situazioni
dell'africa penso all'eritrea e tra
queste appunto
molti sono giovani eritrei che scappano
da un paese difficile da un regime
politico molto duro pensate che in
eritrea il servizio militare ha durata
illimitata
i giovani vengono utilizzati i giovani
militari vengono utilizzati come forza
lavoro per costruire le strade nelle
miniere una forma di semischiavitù
praticamente molti scappano si calcola
circa un migliaio a settimana e la
polizia di frontiera al potere di
sparare su chi cerca di lasciare il
paese
ma questi ragazzi non si fanno
intimidire da questo e scappano e inizia
quindi un viaggio tremendo
impressionante perché attraverso paesi
il sud sudan nel sudan l'egitto
poi molti arrivano in libia e poi
attraverso nel mare e che arriva qua
spesso sono dei sopravvissuti lo
sappiamo quanti muoiono in mare e penso
mi viene in mente anche appunto pensando
a questo la storia di un ragazzino di 17
anni che ho incontrato l'anno scorso a
porta venezia qui a milano perché era lì
il luogo dove un po si radunavano i
profughi eritrei e che aveva 17 anni ma
era partito quattro anni prima ci ha
messo quattro anni per arrivare in
italia
questa è la storia di tanti e della
storia anche di molti che arrivano in
sudan vengono spesso concentrati in
alcuni campi e poi però accade che
vengono comprati da dei trafficanti di
uomini che li vendono ad altri
trafficanti di uomini e questo spesso
avviene perché così si ricattano le
famiglie e si chiede un riscatto ma
ancora peggio alcuni vengono anche
uccisi per espiantare i loro organi e
molti di questi finiscono prigioni
ieri di gruppi di di clan beduini nella
penisola del sinai in egitto tra
l'egitto e israele
in quel luogo vengono appunti tenuti in
schiavitù spesso torturati in situazioni
molto molto difficili molti di questi
profughi eritrei sanno che in europa in
italia a milano c'è una donna una donna
straordinaria che si chiama al ganesh
fissa e di origine eritrea cittadina
italiana è un medico e una donna il cui
numero di telefono è in mano a tanti
profughi eritrei che sanno di poter
contare su un aiuto quando arriveranno
in italia e molti di questi profughi
raccontano hanno raccontato dalle
ganasce la loro situazione che si
trovavano prigionieri che si trovavano
sfruttati torturati incarcerati e al
garage ha iniziato a pensare che doveva
fare qualcosa e quindi ha pensato di
andare nel sinai dove c'erano queste
bande di beduini che tenevano queste
persone è andato a conoscere sapeva che
c'era uno shake un capo locale un
musulmano molto autorevole nella zona e
ha voluto andarci a parlare per cercare
di capire se potevano collaborare va nel
sinai è quest'uomo è un po perplesso
vedere questa donna cristiana europea
non capiva bene come mai era lì la fa
aspettare per due giorni nella sua casa
prima di incontrarla però il garage non
si arrende non si rassegna perché vuole
salvare le vite di quelle persone allora
dopo due giorni comincia questo dialogo
questo incontro tra questo musulmano
questo sheikh e questa donna cristiana e
al ganesh spiega la situazione il dramma
di tanti profughi eritrei che sono resi
schiavi dai beduini e spiega anche che
contro la legge dell'islam fare questo
che un vero musulmano non può fare
questo però quest'uomo comincia a capire
e da lì nasce un'amicizia molto bella e
nasce una collaborazione tra queste due
figure tra questa donna cristiana e
quest uomo musulmano
cominciano a capirsi a lavorare insieme
e con la forza del dialogo per la forza
delle parole e della persuasione
convincono
tanti di questi beduini a liberare
queste persone negli ultimi due anni al
ganesha liberato quasi 500 persone
insieme al suo amico musulmano questa
storia ci dice che cosa il dialogo il
dialogo e il lavoro comune di uomini e
donne di fedi diverse che si impegnano
per salvare la vita degli altri che si
impegnano per pacificare situazioni
difficili che lavorano per difendere i
diritti umani di tutti
questo è il dialogo questo è lo spirito
di assisi lo spirito di assisi nasce da
quella grande intuizione che è stata
quella di giovanni paolo ii nel 1986
nella città di francesco d'assisi di
riunire convocare tutti i rappresentanti
delle chiese cristiane delle grandi
religioni mondiale per pregare gli uni
accanto agli altri non più gli uni
contro gli altri
per pregare per la pace era l'intuizione
in anni in cui le religioni non
contavano
quanto siamo ancora prima della caduta
del muro in piena guerra fredda le
religioni non contavano tanto ma
giovanni paolo ii aveva intuito la
grande forza che c'è nelle religioni
quando gli uomini di fede le donne di
fede vanno nel profondo delle loro
convinzioni religiose
e allora che sanno sono capaci anche di
vedere il meglio che c'è negli altri e
diventano capaci di lavorare per la pace
come sappiamo come dire c'è un po una
contraddizione in fondo oggi vediamo
quanto la religione può essere benzina
gettata sui conflitti però le religioni
possono essere anche quel unguento buono
che cura le ferite e questo è successo
in tanti paesi
quell incontro di assisi incontro che
parla appunto di dialogo di incontro di
preghiera per la pace nella città di
francesca non dobbiamo dimenticare che
francesco d'assisi è stato un uomo del
dialogo che in tempo di crociate
attraversato i confini tra mondo
cristiano e mondo musulmano per andare a
parlare al sultano quindi la figura di
francesco parla di pace assisi parla di
pace nel mondo
quell'incontro fu un incontro
straordinario con questa immagine è
forse una delle immagini più
significative del novecento e
quell'incontro a quell'incontro la
comunità di sant'egidio ha lavorato per
che portò appunto dei rappresentanti
musulmani e dopo quell'incontro abbiamo
pensato che non poteva restare una bella
cartolina di un giorno ma che se dovesse
continuare questo spirito è lo spirito
di assisi la comunità di sant'egidio la
portata avanti con fedeltà con tenacia
da quell'anno ogni giorno ogni anno in
città diverse in italia in europa e
fuori dell'europa si realizzano incontri
interreligiosi di questo tipo
rappresentanti delle grandi religioni
che si trovano a s'incontrano si
interrogano sulle domande che vengono
dai conflitti dalla povertà
le grandi domande del mondo
contemporaneo e che insieme insieme
cercano di costruire appunto
un mondo più umano un mondo più
pacificato
questo percorso è attraversato tante
città arrivata anche a milano nel 2000
prima nel 93 ma prima volta una seconda
volta nel 2004 sono state incontri molto
significativi si è creato come un grande
cammino che ha coinvolto e coinvolge
centinaia di persone che poi si
impegnano nei loro paesi e questo
cammino ha un cammino che aiuta tanti
aiutato tanto e cambiare idea a vincere
pregiudizi e impegnarsi insieme con
altri per costruire la pace penso ai
rappresentanti delle religioni che
lavorano in nigeria o in medioriente in
iraq o nella repubblica centroafricana
paesi dove c'è un conflitto che è anche
un conflitto di tipo religioso
ma tutto questo
da dove nasce dove nasce questo discorso
del dialogo interreligioso beh nasce
molto
io credo dall'amicizia con i poveri chi
è più altro da noi di un anziano che
vive solo un istituto di un bambino rom
che vive in un campo fangoso la
periferia delle nostre città di un
immigrato che arriva da un paese lontano
o di una persona che vive per strada
stando accanto ai poveri diventando
amici dei poveri
la comunità di sant'egidio ha imparato
entrare un po nella vita degli altri a
capirne la sensibilità a capire il
proprio punto di vista a leggere anche
appunto le sofferenze le domande le
aspettative la ricerca anche di un
futuro diverso le speranze i sogni
insomma noi abbiamo incontrato lì e
abbiamo imparato come dire con i poveri
quell'arte del dialogo e dell'incontro
peraltro i primi musulmane che abbiamo
incontrato era nei nostri amici
immigrati
molti poi ci dicono ma voi come fate a
parlare con i musulmani ma italiana come
ci si parla
è così che si incontra la gente si
incontra con tratto umano con imparando
appunto quell'arte del dialogo e
dell'incontro che anche uscire dal
monologo questo è il dialogo rompere il
monologo rompere la tendenza a parlare
solo su di noi di noi ma guardare agli
altri ascoltare gli altri e costruire
con gli altri un futuro diverso
allora vorrei chiudere solo con un detto
musulmano che mi ha insegnato un mio
amico marocchino che dice una mano da
sola non applaude
grazie